I'm in New Zealand's beautiful Milford
Sound which is actually not a sound but
a Ford so one question you might ask is
what is a Ford well the answer is it's a
giant channel carved out of the rock and
it was carved by glaciers so ice moving
down through here at incredibly slow
speeds how long do you think it would
take a glacier like carve out a valley
like no.14 the--the yeah easily
hey yeah he's this I know you did so
I've been going around asking people how
old is the earth wow that's a good
question I'm not really sure good
question um millions a yard sale or yard
now millions years out very four four
five millions years a couple of million
years olds Oh millions millions of years
2.3 million no
do I hear four do I hear four million
okay it's a million 10 million 20
million nice
I like how you doubled them down I
noticed 36 million 46 million forty
billion all right say like three or four
months are millions and millions a
billion years Oh a couple billion years
old 4 billion 4.2 billion billion yeah
yes yeah like this so the answer is it's
four and a half billion years old that's
really quite a long time but I think to
most people the difference between a
million years and a billion years is
well it's difficult to imagine so let's
try to put this in perspective if you
imagine that my arm span is the history
of the earth with the starting of the
earth at the tip of my right fingers
then what life would have formed
somewhere around my right forearm but
from there all the way up to about my
left forearm only we only had
single-celled creatures then just before
my left wrist we get the first fish than
amphibians dinosaurs around my left palm
and finally mammals around the base of
my finger
now dinosaurs lived up until the second
knuckle on my on my right middle finger
and humans have only been around for
well basically the very tip of my middle
finger so if you think about the scale
of the the Earth's evolution on that
time scale humans have been here a very
short time and in fact the earth has
been here for a huge period of time four
and a half a billion years